in case you didn't know this already
religions
are complex and the deeper you die the
more you realize what you have yet to
learn
even in a tradition like sufism which in
itself
is a part of the larger religion of
islam we quickly realized that it is
consists of a huge inner diversity and
complexity
not all sufis practice in the same way
and they don't believe in the same
things
in fact sufism is very famously divided
up into different
mystical orders in arabic nurse turok in
plural or
tariqa path in singular now not all
sufis adhered to a
specific sufi order and the order
structure was not the standard during
the first few centuries of its
development but from the 12th century or
so the
the the way of structuring the sufi or
surfacing into these different
mystical orders became the norm and
immensely popular
and remain so until today in this video
which is a collaboration with the
excellent historical channel al
mukhadema
we will be exploring one of the most
famous and widespread of these orders
and mochadema's video on the history of
islamic presence in the region of
qingyang
in china gives us some of the historical
context but
in this companion video we will be in
particular
diving into the tariqah called
nakshpandiya
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the nakshbandiya or nakshbandi order is
an old one dating back to the
late middle ages it is widespread across
the world today and has often been
considered one of the more
orthodox sufi orders as we will see why
soon but if you watched any of my
previous videos you should know by now
that any discussions about things like
orthodoxy is often pretty useless the
origins of this tariqa is usually
considered to be the central asian sufi
saint and master baha'i
muhammad al-nakshband who was also the
namesake of the order itself
being from modern-day uzbekistan and
living in the 14th century
the order that was founded around his
teaching would become immensely popular
in the following centuries
especially in the eastern parts of the
muslim world
places like central asia and the indian
subcontinent
while baha'i is the main figure and
founder of the order
it is said that it wasn't consolidated
into a distinct tariqa until under the
influence
of a later follower called allah
was a second generation disciple of
nakshpant himself
and he was very important in the
establishment of the nakshpandiya as a
proper
order at tariqah the nakshbandiya is
quite unique
in terms of its chain of authority of
spiritual authority
you see all sufi orders and really all
sufi masters
trace their spiritual authority in a
chain called the silsila
that always eventually go back to the
prophet muhammad himself
so if you take basically any sufi sheikh
today like
for example the current leader of the
nakshpandi khalid
he received his jazza which is his
authority to teach and
spiritual instruction by his master
nazim al-haqqani
who received his spiritual transmission
of spiritual authority
from his master sheikh abdullah
al-ristani
and so on in a chain of masters that
eventually reached the prophet muhammad
himself
now all sufi orders and all sufi masters
have a chain like this
simply the only difference being that
they have different
variations on this chain with different
masters and different places and so on
but
every sufi order has a sidzilla a chain
of spiritual authority and transmission
the uniqueness of the nakshpandiya is
firstly that they have two main stems or
chains one of which goes through
ali the prophet's son-in-law and cousin
and this is probably one of the most
widespread or common ways for these
chains to work and
in this way ali is very important for
most of the sufi orders as being one of
the main persons
that traces this chain back to the
prophet muhammad but the nakshmandia
have
another chain that goes through the
first caliph abu bakr
before reaching the prophet muhammad and
this chain is often referred to
as the golden chain and it's the one
that most
nakshpandi masters emphasized the most
but in any case the nakshpandiya in all
of its inner diversity and
just like all other sufi orders has
certain characteristic practices and
teachings
that distinguish it from other orders
now it will be a mistake to think that
these different sufi orders or sufism in
general
has a distinct theology of its own in a
distinct
way for the most part sufis and history
and in these different sufioris have
followed one of the
established schools of kalam or theology
like the
asharis or the maturities for example
even if they were often also
hostile to speculative theology in
general instead what distinguishes these
different
sufi orders from each other and from
non-sufis is primarily
their practices now as i said the the
word for these orders in arabic is
tariqa which literally means a
path so they could be seen as different
paths different
methods and techniques to reach intimacy
with god also sometimes called
union with god and perhaps the most
characteristic and distinguishing
feature of the nakshbandi path
is their practice of silent vicar now
the good is probably the main
practice in all of sufism it literally
translates to remembrance and is a
practice in which
god is invoked through recalling his
different names or through phrases like
there is no god but god this is in fact
a practice that
basically all sufi orders and sufis
generally take part in in some way
but it can take on many different forms
it is
usually chanted rhythmically in a group
and on occasion even different
instruments like frame drums can be used
but the nakshbandia is unique in the
sense that their practice of the vikr is
entirely
silent that is it is not chanted out
loud but only in the heart
or mind of the practitioner the
justification for this is usually that
it will prevent the person from being
caught
preoccupied with the movement of the
tongue instead of being engrossed
in directing the heart towards union
with god
on top of this the nakshpandiya has also
generally rejected the use of
music as any kind of spiritual practice
there are of course many other different
aspects that are unique to the
nakshpandiya that we could discuss but
we don't really have time to go through
all of it in this video
there is for example the so-called 11
nakshbandi principles
supposedly authored by the founders of
the order and i'll leave them on the
screen so you can pause and read it
through if you want
but as of right now i will only be
exploring one of these principles which
is also i think a very characteristic
aspect of the nakshpandi order
and this is the idea of solitude in the
crowd this idea can briefly be
summarized as an attitude where
the mystic is to be internally detached
from the world
and only preoccupied with god while
outwardly
he or she still participate actively in
society
in other words the nakshbandi sufis have
generally
rejected the more kind of extreme forms
of renunciation that we find in many
other orders like the
shishtiya or the khalwatiya for example
there is no living alone in a cave in
the mountains in the nakshpandi order
generally at least this has also led to
the fact that nakshbandis have often
taken a reactive role in social and
political questions
in central asia and in india for example
they were often very close
with the emperors or the kings and
influenced the political
scene to a very large degree now the
nakshmander is not the only tariq or
order that has this kind of active
attitude of course but
it can still be said to be a very
characteristic aspect of their
path like i would say at least and
because of all of you above the
nakshpandiya it is often considered a
sober sufi order as it doesn't contain
many of the
other sort of ecstatic practices and
teachings that we find elsewhere
this active attitude of the order is
also probably one of the reasons that it
has been so successful in its wider
spread
as i've said previously they were
especially popular in central asia
and perhaps most prominently in on the
indian subcontinent
during mughal times for example the
nakshbandiya
rose to great prominence and often
influenced the politics and the court of
immorals
to a large degree in the indian context
as well as elsewhere
the nakshpandiya has often come to be
seen as representing
islamic orthodoxy and as being the
orthodox
sufi order of course statements like
this are incredibly problematic as terms
like orthodoxy are
always fluid and subjective but what it
does point to
is that the nakshbandis have often had a
more strict and conservative way of
applying or relating to the sharia the
islamic law
as well as its general sufi practices
in mughal india for example it often
stood in great contrast to the other
major orders like the shishtiya and
khadiriya
on a number of grounds the nakshbandis
as we have seen rejected any form of
sama or
music as a spiritual practice something
that was
widespread in both the shishti and
khandaria
they also performed this silent wikked
as opposed to the more vocal form which
was more prevalent
and the nakshbandi masters often openly
criticized the other orders for
not adhering properly to islamic law as
a result
they came to be seen by their supporters
as guardians of the islamic law
against the innovations of the heterodox
sufis
of course it's important to remember
that the supporters of the other orders
saw themselves in the exact same way
but when scholars talk about the
nakshbandiya today
this is the common image of a more
orthodox
sufi order that adhered strictly to
islamic law
in fact one of the most prominent and
influential figures in the history of
the nakshpandi order
appears in this very context in mughal
india
in the person of ahmed sir hindi he is
seen by many as a mujad a reviver of the
religion
and wrote a treatise he called
al-maktubat
where he openly criticizes some of the
other sufis in india
and their practices and ideas he
wanted to revive the religion and sufism
by returning it to a strict adherence to
the sunnah of the prophet muhammad
one of the main aspects of sufism in
india that he criticized
was the doctrine called or the unity of
being
so here we actually do get into a bit of
theology in general as i've said the
sufis follow the established schools of
theology
but they are distinguished from
non-sufis in their insistence on the
imminence of god in
the world and the possibility of
reaching intimacy with him
in this life the goal of much of sufi
practice throughout all of sufism
can be said to be the concept known as
fana which means annihilation this is
the
annihilation of the individual self into
the absolute reality that is god
and this concept has been understood in
many different ways throughout history
but generally we are usually not dealing
with
the idea that the individual is actually
united or
merged with god this mos sufis would
reject this idea
instead we are talking about a
realization of the non-existence of the
individual
self and thus a realization that god is
really the only thing that exists in
reality
the doctrine of which i already
dedicated several videos to
is usually traced back to the andalusian
sufi ibn arabi
and his school in criminally short terms
it is the idea that god is the only
reality
being identified with being or existence
itself
in arabic would which is thus ultimately
one
hence the unity of being ahmed sidhindi
was very critical of this idea
as he equated it with pantheism and
associated it with
hindu ideas so instead he proposed a
modification of this doctrine
which he called which means the unity of
the witnessing
the distinction here is that the
experience of uniting with god
is only a subjective experience that
does
not mean that it is objective a truth or
objective reality as such
thus trying to maintain the absolute
separation between god and creation
but now as many scholars like william
chidik have pointed out the whole idea
is really based on a misunderstanding of
ibn arabis doctrine
and when we dive deeper we realize that
they are essentially saying the same
thing
this is one perspective on it at least
and i will probably be dedicating a
whole other video to this question in
particular
so for now let's return to the main
subject of the video ahmed sidhindi's
ideas were so influential and
and popular that a whole branch one of
the largest branches of the order
was formed around him called the
nakshbandi mujadidi he and his followers
also had a significant influence in the
mughal court
whereas royals like akbar shah jahan
jahangir and
had been primarily influenced by the
shishti and khadiri orders
the emperor aurangzeb and many of his
successors
were nakshbandis and the rule is often
considered to have
inaugurated a more strict and
unforgiving period in mughal rule
which reflects the nakshpandi's more
kind of strict and conservative approach
to suvism and islam generally but the
order also spread outside of india and
central asia
it eventually made its way to china for
example which is a subject that
al-qaeda deals with in his video it also
spread to
anatolia and the ottoman empire and the
sort of egypt and then damascus syria
iraq and all
it eventually became an incredibly wide
spread
order which remains until today it is
one of the most widespread sufi orders
in the world at this point
there are major branches of the
nakshpandia in places like the united
states and
europe as well as in asia and the middle
east the nakshbandi haqqani order is
especially popular in the west and has a
strong presence online
to some degree the nakshpandi are still
seen as one of the more orthodox sufi
orders because many of their doctrines
and
characteristics that have been discussed
in this video but there's also a wide
span
of different branches and groups that
can strongly differ from each other
ranging from very traditional orthodox
forms
to more some of the more prominent
neo-sufi so-called movements in the
world today
the nakshbandi order is thus a very
complex tariqa
it originated in central asia and what
is today uzbekistan
but has since spread across most parts
of the world
it is characterized by some of its
teachings and practices like the silent
vicar which
makes it stand out and add to the nuance
and complexity and diversity of
sufism in particular of islam and
religion
in general don't forget to watch
al-mukhadem's video on the history of
islamic presence in tinjan china
it connects to some of the discussions
in this video
you should also definitely subscribe to
his channel it is one of the best
sources for islamic political history
that you can find
online and has some absolutely beautiful
visuals to go along with it i
highly recommend it as always i would
like to extend my
warmest gratitude towards my patrons
without which this channel will not be
possible
especially i would like to extend thanks
to some of my new patrons
manuel fishman and
thank you all so much i would of course
highly appreciate if some
other viewers would like to become
patrons as well this would help me
continue to make these videos i will
leave a link to my patreon page in the
description
you can also of course leave a one-time
donation to my paypal account which i
will also link to
in the description if you want more
videos like this on different suvi
orders then please let me know in the
comments this is one of my favorite
subjects as i'm sure some of you already
know
if you aren't subscribed to the channel
then of course i would highly appreciate
if you would subscribe
and i will see you next time
[Music]
you